I'm just really happy that there you
know that there's a conversation that's
you know come about and people can
understand really how hard it is to to
speak out olivia munn on her decision to
go public about her the predator co-star
a sexual offender who was convicted in
2010 on charges involving a
fourteen-year-old girl his scene with
Olivia was cut once she discovered his
past and alerted the studio GT spoke
with the actress at the film's LA
premiere truthfully the amazing
outpouring of support and shared outrage
from fans social media the news outlets
that has been honestly the most I think
surprising thing just because to have
everyone on the same page and and it's
usually you know quietly at home you're
like going you know you're frustrated
but it's like everyone kind of is saying
the same things that you know we're kind
of going through my head so that's
honestly been the most amazing thing
just to see that it's not just in
Hollywood that this happen it's not just
having to me I mean there are girls who
you know speak out against you know the
you know star baseball player and then
they get shunned I'm like there this is
like they this happens all around the
world and
and the dialogue that's come about it
has been so important and the support my
co-star has has been amazing and it's
been really special for me to receive
that so I'm just really happy that you
know we're in a time in the world where
you know people are listening et also
spoke with director Shane Black who
fought back tears I have reached out to
Olivia
I felt that I owed her that call that
apology and I'm very sorry for any pain
that she's felt so I did reach out but I
reached out privately I've caused her
pain it's on me it's my fault you know I
made a decision which was a very bad
it's not about the fact that I was as
shocked to discover what's going on and
reading these horrible things in the
paper but that's still on me I'm the
captain to the ship and I'm not allowed
to make choices for people I'm not
allowed to just treat this like we're
kids in college and putting friends and
movies because this is the big leagues
and I felt like I had let people down
that caused pain to the cast and that is
not acceptable with it and so I felt yes
that I had to reach out it's very
important to me that she be she receive
a proper apology the private the proper
apology if she wants it Olivia's
co-stars praised her for her courage and
strength in speaking out it's very
important the idea that she felt that
she was isolated and or possibly being
vilified for speaking up for having a
sexual offender on her cancer tried to
hook up with his 14 year old cousin its
skeevy and it's nasty and I can't
believe that the law says but you're not
technically allowed to ask that needs to
change it's not like being pregnant or
how old you are this is something that
can affect people's safety and you need
your own set for such a long period of
time
around so many different people you
deserve to know who you sharing the
space very important I support her I'm
very proud of her were dear friends and
I and I'm so glad that she brought it's
everybody's attention and I'm so glad
that Fox handled the situation
appropriately
you